citizens of the reject Nation law-abiding citizens
of the reject Nation we're here for more b99 we're
gonna watch episodes 19 and perhaps 20
of season five are you excited G yes I am
heck yeah leave a like on the video and if you
want to see the full reaction come on over to
patreon.comreal rejects thanks to prepper
for cutting these down let's do this thing
Here Comes The Bachelor all dressed in
my nice jacket I only wear for special
events ah you're already on fire you're on fire
this is the elite party Squad I want you guys
to think of me as one of the boys so tonight
I'll be swapping out my captain's hat for my
Kangol hat and go ahead I will
definitely call you Raymond
Raymond of the cankle heads ribbon
of the Kingo hat time to party yes
there it is batch boys isn't bad Raymond in the
Kangol hat that's bat street boys I'm so excited
for tonight thank you to my best friend Kylie
for organizing this thank you for coming ladies
and gentlemen I like how Amy has one friend
outside of the precinct and my gift to you is
a cray cray night a funky fun I fear I've already
made the biggest mistake in my life just wait till
four drink Amy shows up I thought we'd start by
discussing the etymology of the word Bachelorette
or we could just play Never Have I Ever maybe
later also amps definitely Beatrice looks great
you guys know how the game works right you drink
if you have done it okay bats boys bartender now
let's just grab a couple cabs what do we have
here do you ever notice how blue this show looks
what just happened well that was maybe we
should see what's in it scavenger hunt had sex
back of a car Thalia was a school bus we've
done like nine rounds of this and you haven't
drunk once maybe we should play something
else that actually gets you drunk that's
not true I've done stuff oh my God you gotta
go crazy today never never I ever had a one
night stand with a guy from a band whoops
yes I have whoa dang watch out Madonna I
told Jake that you really liked that band and
he booked it for your wedding as a surprise
yes surprise is it The Dan Band Jesus wandering
around aimlessly and we haven't done one bachelor
party thing whatever you'd like I could share a
lewd story Kevin got me quite horny this morning
I'm hungry no you're in luck the fanny pack is
filled with granola I don't want Fanny granola I
want steaks and whiskey perhaps that's something
a limo can answer oh nice it is to find you is
that a Serbian accent it is write that down
for later I'll see you in six hours six hours
oh ditch you okay let's not get skirts just
because we've been doing this for 93 minutes
and we haven't figured out one damn clue
that's why I said oh it's got the whole
thing cracked all we have to do is decipher this
list of thousands of random numbers I wonder one
of them is six nine pretty sure you mean 69 but
I'm so hungry I can't even appreciate horndogram
horndog regmen in the Kangol hat Charles would
be so upset if we bailed or what if Charles never
knew we'd have to do any of his dumb puzzles
right instead we can spend the next six hours
eating and drinking and talking about how we lost
our V cards nicely done that's real slang there's
a receipt for a party boat rental and also a cake
delivery to a doc down at Bergen Beach that's been
under no circumstances will we do any bachelor
partying without Charles oh jeez Bachelor of
Adventure Kylie you should talk less sorry I have
to direct it somewhere nice to meet you by the way
Charles already gave us a name that
is the only one we're gonna use
Jesus Jake oh I'm so scared the
kidnappers have to be tied up and
where are you guys I don't want to say in
case the kidnappers are listening smart
what's close should we order another round [Music]
what is his name put some of my thoughts down
just to let them out so I don't explode no
matter how lame that dude's man purse is she did
it with one of the Workaholics how long were you
with crying wedding band man bun not that long
I doubt he even remembers me Amy Santiago ladies
and gentlemen my life is [Laughter] we dated for
three months that is not a one night Charles has
to think we're totally sober and we solved his
puzzle I've seen you do enough of these hair
brain schemes in order to play along if Charles
asks what's wrong I'll just put on a question
nothing they're gonna fall in the water
aren't they oh yeah we're nailing this hello
Charles surprise welcome to the party
pal oh that's actually awesome we
get to the best part steaks and
shots oh no what does that mean
oh you guys don't mess this up you guys
don't mess this up he was everything I
thought he'd be never before has a person
so perfectly met my expectations I know
Reginald Vel Johnson the best Reginald Vel
Johnson from Sergeant Powell was a part of
my oh no I have one more surprise for you if I
could have your eyes ears and emotional cores
I'd like Knight had to be the biggest most
special bachelor party ever my friend our
new ordinary man in fact you are 24
Karat hey the dye hair photo 24 carat
gold is that a phrase I say no like the coins
from the hunt yes of course from those now okay
please present your gold coin no here's the deal
Terry's coin fell out of his pocket and we lost it
we just didn't have the heart to tell you oh no it
costs 800 all right Terry will pay me back later
oh geez I hate mine you hate your coin yes I
thought it was chocolate but you hate chocolate
it has too much taste you guys didn't do the
scavenger hunt can you call yourselves The
Bachelor actually we call ourselves the steak
studs what are you doing talk to you about
a gig you have coming up Jake Peralta booked
it yeah you're winning if you knew that then
why did you take it I wrote you a love song
I'm gonna sing it and I'm gonna win you back
then we're gonna be on the Today Show tell him
something came up and you have to cancel the gig
not happening I'm gonna get on that stage and I'm
gonna play Amy come back fine maybe come back I'm
canceling your band that'll just cost you fifteen
thousand dollars well when I heard it was your
wedding I knew your fiance would cancel when
he found out about us he didn't read the terms
the t's and C's we shouldn't have lied
to you but all of this the puzzle it's
what you wanted not me just wanted to
hang out with my friends don't let me
stop hang out with your friends all you
want because I'm leaving Charles yeah
coins he hit all over the city they were so
expensive also why does he keep saying I'm 24
karat gold no idea zero sense we'll have to figure
it out later in the meantime we gotta find those
I'm sure if you find it you'll know why all we
have to do is solve the entire six hour scavenger
hunt immediately toss me that Sextant guys we can
do this we're way too drunk be someone that knows
where those coins are right Charles he's probably
digging up the gold coins but who would know where
the gold coins are Charles knows where they are
but where is he no wait a second we're super drunk
and we're in a loop we need to find someone who
isn't Charles Reginald Vale Johnson yes steal the
contract and destroy it destroy a legal document
I can't do that you're right I'm a boring square
who's never actually had a crazy well you're
gonna have a fun bachelorette party tonight
only control so much she's got ta explode I'm
just lying record executive at executive records
lucious lying I've heard
that name anyway I love you
I love you family matters Carl Winslow made me
want to become a cop come on Terry you already
have like six other reasons you became a cop
this is not your moment and for the record
you're gonna tell us where those coins are hidden
or you're going to regret it stay here all night
I'll tell you where he is yes thank you so
much also we're gonna need you to take us
there because we're all too drunk to drive take a
cap I'm already represented by my mom God you're a
turd well this turd is your best friend's Future
Husband hey wait no doink [Music] drunk Amy go
[Music] that's gonna cost you
fifteen thousand dollars to
I've never loved you and that your whole family
is a bunch of friggins [Music] that looks [Music]
never have I ever broken his heart hired him
to play at my weddings you could have a great
aneurysmen especially after midnight so
I can now say whatever I want tonight
was awesome and I loved hanging out with you dorks
oh wow that is sweet Sheena dork is actually a
Celtic word meaning lungfish capturing so hard
this is where he's coming to wait for you like
that Hitchcock Skully actually came in handy
I'm the one who should apologize I overdid it
tonight I hope things are gonna change between
us I'm getting married I mean didn't you make
me less of a priority when you and Genevieve
got together yes you made an enemy for life
and I'm telling Bruce Willis you suck it's good
but it's important to be made up my best friend
to Jake and Amy [Applause] to Jake and Amy nice he
left me a very long message with a lot of details
oh no I'm just kidding I'll never bring it up
again thank you you're the sweetest oh I love
you I love you too turtlebug oh uh do I still
need to be here yes Reginald we're all toasted
and we need rides home [Laughter] oh it's fun
when best men throw the groom a bachelor party
that's right isn't it it's definitely
fun when they decide everything you
ought to do and it's not up to you a way to
justify someone not throwing we should watch
it I'm not justifying anything I'm accepting the
fact that we did not plan a very good bachelor
party for you because if you don't plan a bachelor
party at all play the next episode John I am not
a good person two best men did nothing show me
going is the name of the episode 23 Jake hurry
up starving sorry sorry sorry I just I just need
to grab my wall wow whoa Willy Wonka Paddington
three kids in a trench coat
fine I was trying
excellent excellent cold open okay before we
get going Sergeant Jefferson suggested that
it would improve morale if we started the
meeting with some consensual non-work job
exactly jabber it's going to go well it's just
a regular morning for me woke up again simply
unavail we have a meeting at a new multi-agency
multi-state task force it's a double multi it's
a multi multi you're better everything than I do
they're taking down a street racing gang that's
been using souped-up cars to transport drugs
across state lines it's a real life Fast and
the Furious movie they glorify family and loyalty
big hard boobs on both men and women guess who's
heading up the task force plus they work for the
government I heard he diffused a bomb with his
teeth because his hands were tighter I heard
he bangs constantly I know how competitive
these task forces can be especially this one
because Boomers come on Hitchcock Mel Gibson
is broken I think Scully did it he says
he says he has his bathroom but who else
would leave a whole rotisserie chicken in there
I'm glad it's broken because it's nice to see
now get in that stall and kill it in there
what sorry I'm a manager now so I'm trying
to be more motivational oh so it's totally cool
for detectives to come down here oh no yeah that
there's always been tension between uniformed
officers and detectives but Rosa is one of the
good guys I'm sure she knows her name you clearly
just texted her the answer no she didn't Alvarado
Tony you were still one of them we all know
now I'm caught in a turf war between my new
Squad and my old Squad I know this is a big
deal for you as a manager but I gotta pee
real bad right right I believe in you woof weird
I've never heard anyone call you that well they
will soon the point is I'm basically a young
Boomer Maxwell are you guys in here Boomer's
not running special unit anymore he shattered
both his legs jumping off the Chrysler Building
also still cool he's going to be an iron
side wait if Boomer's not doing it who's
running the task force detective Brett Booth
from 6-3 that was your word we were in the
academy together during a training exercise
I shot him with a rubber bullet wow goggles
and hit him in the eye it kind of messed up
his depth perception oh but that was a long
time ago I'm sure he's totally fine now it's
forgotten all about it oh well if it isn't Jake
again
you're gonna regret this Peralta oh [Music] how
did he get this for letting us in his task force
just because you blinded him in one eye another
one works just fine no I mean the water cooler
thing was pretty you need an eye patch man
all we have to do is solve it before Booth
is done with his interviews in two days that's
impossible you know hate the word impossible
unless it's immediate followed by the words go
stand protocol what's going on that's real whoa
multiple casualties ESU is on Route and nearby
officers are responding to the scene right now
what the hell this is really real
what are they saying show me going in their
badge number they're telling dispatch that
they're close by and they're responding oh [__]
oh no what was it DS that's our badge number
Rose is there very special episode of b99 I think
it's gonna be the funniest one there's a lot of
untapped comedy shooter situation to help Rosa
ESU is on a scene and the 97 is locking down the
area it's already a zoo they wanted us to remain
on alert but not to respond yeah but that's just
a suggestion like how they tell you to drink
eight cups of water every month a day every
month Jake Sure I'm sure it just blew in there
on accident anyways off to third grade I can't
I dwell on everything I'm a dweller I wake
up every morning I'm worrying about the zika
virus why is nobody talking about zika anymore
tell him you love him Jake 's well just ignore
what's going on together okay let's focus on
the case let's become Street racers hey Charles
Speed Racer right this is exactly what he wears
and the best part is yes just start the race well
I wanted this op to feel normal and races go
wow that's young oh yeah I had to use a wiffle
ball bat just to reach the gas pedal and I never
learned to use the break things went South when
I got addicted to drugs after my best friend died
in an active shooter situation oh I see what I did
Jeeps listen I was thinking Rosa seemed pretty
annoyed about the broken toilet up here and since
she's having a rough day I thought it would
be nice if we got it fixed for her before
she got back because you were supposed to get it
fixed last week so oh god look I get that you're
worried about your own mortality perhaps this
fact will comfort you as an NYPD officer you're
more likely to be crushed by scaffolding than to
die of a job oh God yeah city of scaffolding no no
Sergeant I was only trying to point out that
there are millions of potential Ways to Die
I didn't want to do this but friend is a cow and
she's caught in the Brooklyn Heights shooting
right now so you think of the first people that
ever needed toilet fix because a loved one's
life was in danger yes you're not that's a grim
commentary on the city we live in refresh the news
refresh no news no news good news let's clean
up our desks right that's always good for a
distraction oh no Rosa gave me this notepad
I remember I was all anyone got a notepad it
sounds like her so before you can change your
policy I'm gonna have to ask you a few medical
questions check your vitals great just do it
fast blood pressure is going to be high okay
then let's start with your blood pressure
you know we can skip this part it's always
clocked in at 1 30 over 80. Terry's in Tip Top
shots fired jeez there were shots fired I just
got off the phone there two offices down neither
one of them is Diaz what are we supposed to wait
until one is so we have to go up there we have
not a part of our Squad he doesn't care about
her look I know you're concerned about Diaz I
am ordering you to stay on this Precinct fine
oh yeah oh yeah okay I'm going up to the scene
of the shooting and I need your help I can't
sign tactical gear out of the Armory without
Holt's approval that's our mission objective
first things first let's synchronize our watches
you just don't want this episode's so blue 335
you too will cause a distraction that draws
hold into the bullpen when Holt's not looking
I'll sneak into the office and answer the phone
when the Armory calls asking for approval I'm
captain Holt yeah I don't know something feels
awesome he sounds too white here's how you do
it yo what up so that plumber was useless but
we are too smart and capable people who can
Google it the internet will tell us what to
do she always does I'll just search videos
oh rule 34 Amy you love rules instructional video
from a plumber on how to fix an actual toilet
first thing we gotta do shut up
[Music]
they brought it back that's why you
watch these episodes back to back
that's right it's showtime what oh I just said I
have Showtime the cable channel this must be nice
looking at each other I'm a little worried
that I'm gonna be able to do this oh yes wow
and now they're doing the James Bond torture
penis punch 69 is my band
[Music]
I'm sorry I thought you wanted to
meet baby Carol her surgery was such
a success Charles we got something good
bye what a weirdo anyways thanks for the
gun you just you could just said yes please
bless this flesh oh man oh it works [Music]
oh no no that sounds fine that's
totally normal we picked it
get out of the way why are you disobeying an
order from the commissioner I'm clearly the
good guy here all right if this was the movie no
one would be on your side you're basically the guy
in Ghostbusters who lets all the Ghosts Out they
need someone to help them face their fears and
deal with the reality of the situation okay great
so why don't you do it I try but it didn't work
I'm not particularly skilled at emotional and
I was hoping to actually do something valuable
like help Rosa so you're gonna stand in my way or
not how are you gonna help Rosa yeah what are you
gonna do [__] really do be crazy sorry we should
just give up this was such a dumb idea yeah it
would only matter if we actually thought Rosa was
oh my God we should keep going right definitely
also it's fun to watch you get destroyed by a
toilet yeah try working next to one in a haunted
house you know what I'm trying to keep this line
open so I don't have time for your bull crap
I can't stay here all day I have other things
to do you a traveling nurse man don't pick up me
I'm sorry it's been a tough guy read the room grab
a slice it's probably gonna be a really long night
none of you have eaten anything Toronto where are
you back so soon because I wanted to do something
equipped them all with guns yes we're all going
down how do I deal with the fact that every day
I leave for work I might not come home man I don't
even know Terry I don't have kids yet but I know
you love them I feel like that's all you can
really do right now that I'm getting married
I keep thinking of something normalize that
blood pressure hey look at that 130 over 80.
back to normal I can get out of your hair now oh
nice tells you Andrew Terry's in Tip Top thanks
Jake you know what would make a great movie one
where the hero sits with his friends and they
talk about their emotions I know that you're just
being nice right now but that would be a terrible
movie I mean what would the poster be it would
be The Breakfast Club poster get yourself [Music]
still just going to voicemail okay I don't
have the names of the injured officers but
if Diaz should be paralyzed perhaps you'll
be walking off the elevator at any moment
doing stuff like that man I was just making a
copy downstairs yeah well next time you think
about what I don't know okay Jake hey come
from felt like walking so I took the stairs
also I thought it'd be funny to mess with you
guys Rosa you know I hate pranks little pranks
I do I really do oh I'm feeling into it are you
sure because the journey I went on today taught
me that sometimes it's best to talk let's just
go get a drink and sit in total silence perfect
first I gotta go to cam actually you might
want to check out the ladies room up here
you made it sound like you fixed a toilet yeah
I thought maybe Amy would have pulled something
together in the two minutes I stepped outside
yeah look what I stole from the Barnes oh yeah
wait are you covered in toilet water yes
big time but this is happening oh fine
I kind of feel like I'm lurking Tina get in here
yes they should have made this really real and
really harsh this is the reality of the world
you live in now on Brooklyn nine I think six
episodes of her in a coma and then she just
dies yeah yeah yeah and try and try and mix one
wackier subplot in for the B story every episode
while the main a plot is just everyone's sort of
holding hands and hoping yeah they have a lot of
missed opportunities here very interesting yeah
it's a very interesting choice I mean I I like
what they chose but yes I feel like there's a lot
heavier and more pointed you can go it's weird I
think just having the toilet subplot is fun and it
matches the theme of like we got to do something
for Rosa we got to distract ourselves but also
I feel like you could have used that time in a
different way maybe like what I don't know I mean
like I'm very I want to insult the writers while
the writers are striking John come on never come
on never you want to criticize their hard work
well it's fascinating and I really enjoyed that
they went they don't deserve it hey I should have
written this John is there what I'm saying is
I think computers are just better at this stuff
than people they have way broader understanding
of the prospects of Life uh no I think it's I'm
torn I think it's really nice that they did an
episode that uh matches most people's eye line
when they hear about an active shooter situation
and God forbid that somebody you love is involved
this is all you can do is sit around and wonder
uh and hope and wait and kind of confront the
idea or not and I think that is kind of a clever
and sophisticated Choice there um but I don't know
I mean like I it would have been way too much
if they just made it an action movie certainly
and uh had Jake run off and join the fight I
don't know I don't know if it would have been
worth going into some more you
know harsh territory or not
I caught all that sure
yeah good stuff John uh sure yeah I could have
done that they could have done that I don't know
why did you think it was a mcpeck huh why'd
you think it was a mixed bag I didn't say it
was a mixed bag what's the first thing you said
no I didn't oh I never said it was a mixed bag
yeah so it's I don't know maybe maybe I'm on
correct I think you should play the video back
and you'll find out Greg never said it was a mixed
bag okay in fact we have a recording here on the
computer yeah I know you said something this is
something to the effect of that I said they should
have killed her off no that was it was not the
joke it was not the obvious joke and then the coma
and the six weeks and then she just dies no it
wasn't that part I'm pretty sure that's all I
said all right well you know the the people
can catch us now although it is a mixed bag
say that it's all right I still attest I did not
say all right that it's a mixed bag you know what
I'll I'll but I will say because you're exactly
the one who has the photographic but I will say
it's a mixed bag um okay well why don't you think
now that we've established finally that it might
have been I just wanted to be technical about
it sure of course I think they were trying to
preserve comedy when this show has already done
the comedy just sort of felt uh uh like the same
the company lacked a Nuance approach whereas
before they've had more serious episodes where
they have still managed to maintain the humor in
ways that really worked and here it still had that
like surreal Larger than Life outlandish um comedy
bits that that actually felt like it conflicted uh
with the tone like it actually undercuts some of
the seriousness versus elevating or aiding in it
they've done serious episodes before where they've
maintained the comedy but I didn't feel that way
and here it would feel uh jarringly different in
certain scenes sometimes though it still worked
for me sometimes it was still funny like the the
thing with the phone and and uh when he's trying
to get the gun Hitchcock and Scully fighting
each other I thought was really funny yeah
sometimes it was still really funny and I think
the toilet thing was supposed to represent you
know in a situation that's out of your control you
try to control try to channel your anxieties and
pain somewhere else so you're trying to control
the situation and I think that's ultimately what
they were attempting to represent the the subject
is so relevant and so like this came out in 2018
but you know for 2023 now we know that active
Shooters are a very serious problem in this
day and age very common so it's a very it's very
sensitive and it's very serious it's I I think
honestly they probably should have just leaned a
little bit more serious instead of having instead
of feeling the need to I guess I felt like the Amy
genus subplot especially fell prey to like we need
to keep one of these really light and funny even
though like I agree that the point is like yeah
a situation you can control and doing something
nice to keep the hope alive that the person will
be back if we stop doing this we kind of accept
that she's not coming back but it does feel like
when you cut back to that especially from like
a commercial Gap it is like okay now we're back
into sort of zanier territory when I think they
could have given it some more of that tense pathos
kind of I don't know it seemed like it became more
about them being upset at the task rather than it
revealing that oh we're really just agitated about
the situation and maybe maybe Rose's experience
will factor into later episodes and I get that
you had to keep her away so you're enhancing the
fear and the suspense and it's about the worry
that these that people are going through you
know which is more identifiable I suppose for most
people because they've had a lot of people who've
died from shooting or experience from shooters or
you know had the fear of the unknown of what might
happen to them so I get that I was focused on them
part of me does want to see if this does factor in
a Rose's experience though moving forward it might
not yeah surprises me sometimes when they do that
yeah it would make sense I mean it seemed like at
least just looking at her performance it seemed
like she brought some of that like I believed
her when she's like I don't want to talk about it
um and it fits the button of the episode but yeah
I I think it would be interesting and worthwhile
if they maybe addressed it again and they've
this season been doing more of those serialized
beats yeah yeah so I would hope that that happens
somehow because yeah that is kind of the ultimate
thing I'm like this episode did a lot of things
I really admire but especially thinking back to
some of like to the Terry episode especially I
feel like that one managed to kind of transcend
to a place where you're like yeah this is a very
special episode of but it's also got the charms
they're just all kind of tweaked and attenuated
in in kind whereas this one didn't feel quite
as like balanced yeah I feel like they could
have just started off with it and yeah and then
and and then just have more of a focus on it as
opposed to like that the whole storyline there of
like Jake and uh oh yeah the whole task force yeah
for Cameo supposed to set something up or whatever
um yeah they're the whole other thing in the Fast
and Furious case they had the funny cold open and
I'm like you could have canned all that and not
that I enjoyed all of it but yeah I think it could
have been excise and you could have moved that
to a different episode I think you could have
shortened it because the point is probably like oh
this is a normal day and then this crazy situation
you know impinges on it but I think you could
have established that way quicker but all that
being said I actually still enjoyed the episode
wait yeah no I'm glad they did it there's a lot
of things that I wish they could have done uh
which I know people love when you place your own
rewrite on something but I I still really like the
episode no I'm not just saying that to say that it
was still very enjoyable and and I appreciate the
the attempt at Nuance as well and some of those
moments yeah like when Rosa does return I thought
that was really sweet and tender and it got they
got in the heart feels uh quite a bit there for
me and uh the first episode with the bachelor
party I like how it actually did escalate into Amy
getting to have that experience where she did get
to go against the ab code of conduct uh the guest
star was funny and why does kids you know guys
yeah he was really really funny and um the whole
scavenger situation Workaholics what is that guys
the whole scavenger hunt bit was great where
uh you got to see like a naughtier side of
Holt which was great yeah really Randy's side
of it yeah and Reginald Vale Johnson Reginald
Johnson I have that cameo in there legendary
actor Reginald Johnson right really showed up
it's true he is known for those two
roles isn't he those two specific roles
probably like a hundred credits between yeah yeah
that you would he's probably one of those actors
who has like a thousand credits but you only hear
about those two um and yeah boy went all out on it
it's a fun episode from a friend like that I know
one of my great all-time regrets in this life
it's okay no don't worry about it when you guys
rather your family uh worked really hard there
to make sure you were when you renew
your vows we're gonna come up and they
made sure to come up what you don't
realize is that the bachelor party
is all is still going and it's just a
10-year protracted augmented reality
when you guys will throw you all the Bachelor
of a newly made bachelor party I love half of
the kids yes just slicing down the middle
yeah King herod's style you're gonna have
it all good Rob Mia my entire she's like a
dementor yes and then she'll take your half
of the party too yeah we throw you for becoming
a bachelor it'll be a bachelor party for yeah
when you renew your vows sure we'll take
you laser tagging into mini golf and to
Chuck E cheese wow you guys really want
to throw a party we don't clearly don't
know how to throw a party but guys what would
you have done for Greg's bachelor party leave
your best itinerary below and uh put us to
shame and go do the same on the jabby coach
and uh hey do we have time for a shout out or
should we just get on out of here got time for one
shot time for one shout out to five we normally do
who is it gonna be let's shout out I want to shout
Maria Hammond Maria Hammond go for it someone
was being mean to me on her patreon and then
um I don't think Maria Hammond watches the
reactions too the that episode that show sure
of Rick caught that comment oh and like the fierce
Warrior woman that she is I saw it this morning
like I haven't even replied to the comment I mean
I I've acknowledged it in an upcoming video but uh
I just thought I'm already just like immediately
just goes the fact for videos she ran in she ran
in like this yeah checked out the Reich here and
ran in Murray oh man I could really count you know
some strong women in my life and Maria happens
certainly wanted them she just goes in there just
a handles business don't even need to ask uh in
fact I expected I expect it from you now your Rosa
Diaz you don't step in I'm gonna I I blame you I
go where the hell are you Maria why weren't you
there to defend me what's your problem my honor
is here no I can't do it I'm too sensitive values
yeah I so I appreciate you I always whooping ass
on behalf of real Rejects uh you're an absolute
deer and maybe I would have replied I just been so
short on time but I was fast so I'll pop up in the
Gmail like there she is my queen right there
so oh thank you Maria for always being uh the
the the matriarch of the reject Nation and the
heartthrob as well talk to you later dear peace